J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Salut tout le monde. On se retrouve cette semaine pour un épisode sur le mensonge, un thème qui se prête très bien à un épisode de Septante Minutes Avec, puisque le mensonge, on sait tous ce que c'est, on y est tous confrontés,
mais en réalité, il y a pas mal de choses qu'on ignore, pas mal d'idées reçues à corriger.
Et pour ce faire, je reçois Frédéric Tomas,
auditeur de longue date de ce podcast qui est linguiste, ayant aussi étudié la psychologie et dont la recherche se concentre, entre autres choses, sur le mensonge, les menteurs, les techniques pour repérer les mensonges et ainsi de suite.
Qui sont tous des sujets qui risquent de beaucoup intéresser mes camarades autistes, mais aussi sur la question des allégations mensongères de viol dont on a parlé en fin d'interview.
Je vous promets que dans cette interview, nous ne nous dirons que la vérité et rien que la vérité. C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Frédéric Tomas. Salut Frédéric.
Salut Guillaume.
Frédéric, tu es assistant professeur à l'université de Tilbourg, aux Pays-Bas, et tu te spécialises, tu es chercheur en ce qui concerne principalement les questions liées au mensonge.
Est-ce que je t'ai bien décrit ?
Oui, c'est tout à fait ce sur quoi je travaille. J'ai plein d'autres centres d'intérêt de recherche qui peuvent découler de la question du mensonge, mais on va y revenir, je suppose.
J'aime tout ce qui est couacs dans la communication.
C'est ça. Tu es arrivé au mensonge parce que tu es attiré par les couacs, les petits bugs dans la communication.
Qu'est-ce que t'entends par là ?
Je suis intéressé par tout ce qui sort d'une communication attendue et classique.
C'est-à-dire tout ce qu'on pourrait attendre d'un échange sincère entre personnes au quotidien et tout ce qui peut en dévier dans nos attentes.
Donc ça couvre des questions comme le mensonge et par extension des formes de mensonges bien particulières.
On en reparlera, mais les fausses allégations d'agressions sexuelles, par exemple, sont des thématiques sur lesquelles je me suis penché.
Mais il y a aussi les théories du complot-
Mmh.
Les fake news, et tous les comportements, par extension, qui sortent aussi de la norme. Donc tout ce qui a trait au harcèlement, tout ce qui a trait aux violences domestiques.
Donc voilà, tout ce qui, en fait, n'est pas de la psychologie du quotidien ou du comportement quotidien.
C'est ça. Ce que tu estimes sortir de la norme, c'est-à-dire la norme, c'est : on se comprend, on dit la vérité, on est parfaitement clair.
Mmh-mmh.
Et quand ça bug, quand il y a du mensonge, de l'ironie, ce genre de choses, à ce moment-là, toi, ça t'attire.
Ah, c'est là que, pour moi, ça devient intéressant.
C'est-- Alors les gens vont me prendre pour un fou, peut-être, mais je trouve que c'est là qu'il y a quelque chose de beau, en fait, c'est qu'on sort du cadre attendu, on sort de ce qu'on,
de ce qu'on peut prédire chez l'autre, en fait, et il y a quelque chose
qui part vers une nouvelle voie.
Quelqu'un va nous mentir, quelqu'un va diverger de la théorie officielle sur un événement, quelqu'un ne va pas se comporter comme il ou elle devrait avec quelqu'un d'autre.
C'est là que moi, ça commence à m'intéresser.
D'accord. Pourquoi ? Qu'est-ce qui explique ce vice chez toi, cette passion ?
Je trouve ça... En fait, je trouve-- Ce sont des comportements plus rares, généralement.
Pas forcément. Il y a des gens qui mentent beaucoup. On en parlera plus tard, mais...
C'est vrai qu'il y a des gens qui mentent beaucoup, mais quotidiennement, l'être humain standard, on va dire-
Mmh.
Ment une à deux fois par jour. Sur tous les actes communicationnels qu'on a-
Ok, c'est relativement peu et en même temps, c'est beaucoup. Je sais pas.
On est d'accord que c'est plus que ce qu'on attend.
Oui.
Parce qu'on les voit pas beaucoup, mais c'est peu comparé à tous les échanges qu'on peut avoir.
Et ça vient d'où cette mesure-là, de une à deux fois par jour ?
Ce sont des mesures qui sont auto-rapportées.
Ouais.
Donc, on demande aux gens-
Peut-être qu'ils mentent en disant ça
Voilà, c'est-- alors, c'est toujours le risque-
Peut-être que le mensonge par jour, c'est quand tu leur demandes combien de fois ils mentent.
Tout à fait d'accord, mais ce qui est intéressant, donc c'est une vieille étude à la base, c'est une étude de nonante-six, mais elle a été répliquée en deux mille vingt-et-un.
Ok.
Avec les mêmes résultats. Alors, soit les participants continuent à mentir de manière régulière sur la fréquence à laquelle ils mentent au quotidien-
Et peut-être que c'est-- À partir du moment où on leur demande de compter combien de fois ils mentent, peut-être que ça les fait réfléchir à : « Tiens, mais c'est vrai que je mens quand même beaucoup.
Je dois peut-être moins mentir. Je suis sur le point de mentir. Je devrais peut-être pas... » C'est compliqué.
C'est tout à fait possible, mais si c'était le cas, on ne retrouverait pas cet effet de manière aussi large dans la population.
Oui, c'est vrai que c'est une grande échelle, ouais.
Voilà, c'est vraiment des études à grande échelle. Ce qui est très, très intéressant, c'est qu'il y a vraiment un petit pour cent de gens qui mentent énormément.
Mmh-mmh. Les politiciens.
Je serais pas allé jusque là. Mais des personnes qui ont ce besoin de mentir relativement régulièrement.
D'accord. Ah oui, un besoin.
Voilà, c'est-- ou qui ne s'en rendent même plus compte. Et dans ce cas-là, on tombe dans des traits pathologiques.
On va revenir là-dessus, oui.
La mythomanie, voilà, c'est cette volonté, ou cette-- en fait, on est même plus conscient qu'on ment et que le mensonge nous a dépassé.
On en reparlera juste après. Mais donc, ce qui est intéressant, c'est quand tu me disais : normalement, les gens ne mentent pas, normalement, tout se passe bien, etc.
Est-ce qu'il y a pas un biais chez toi au niveau de ce que tu attends de la part des gens, c'est-à-dire une honnêteté ?
Est-ce que t'es pas un genre de personne qui veut que les gens disent la vérité ? Et le mensonge, finalement, ça te débecte un peu.
Est-ce que... Je mets peut-être beaucoup de mots dans ta bouche, mais tu peux...
Non, non, mais c'est une réflexion qui est intéressante. Je pense qu'en fait, ce qui moi m'a vraiment fasciné dans le mensonge, c'est que c'est un acte quotidien qui est invisible.
Ok.
On le voit pas. Et on va révéler peut-être un point central de cet épisode, c'est que le mensonge, on ne peut pas le détecter à cent pour cent.
C'est impossible.
Spoiler.
Mais il y a d'autres approches qui peuvent être intéressantes. Restez quand même dans l'épisode. Non, moi, ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup, c'est ce côté caché, mais présent.
Ok.
Et tu parlais d'une espèce de biais de vérité, un biais d'honnêteté. En fait, on l'a tous.
D'accord.
On l'a tous au quotidien. Quand on parle avec tout le monde, on s'attend à ce que l'autre nous dise la vérité. Et même lorsque l'autre ment, on a cette tendance à croire ce que l'autre nous dit.
Et on a vraiment ce-- heureusement d'ailleurs qu'on a ce biais d'honnêteté.
Ok.
Si on devait se poser la question à chaque mot que l'autre dit : Tiens, tiens, tiens, est-ce qu'il serait pas en train de m'arnaquer, là ?
Déjà, ce podcast durerait longtemps, mais surtout, on aurait des relations sociales très, très compliquées.
On serait très seuls, à mon avis.
Tu parlais d'un biais, tu me disais qu'on a tous ce biais et je te parlais aussi de... Est-ce que tu fais un jugement de valeur, toi, par rapport au mensonge ?
Non.
Non ? Tu trouves ça normal, tu trouves ça tout à fait humain.
C'est nécessaire, en fait.
Ok.
C'est-- dans la société, c'est nécessaire.
Intéressant.
Tout comme on a besoin de croire en l'authenticité de l'autre pour avoir des relations sociales coopératives, on va dire.
On a besoin de les arnaquer par derrière.
Exactement.
Je l'aurais pas formulé comme ça, mais oui, pourquoi pas. Dans l'idée, en tout cas, on a besoin parfois pour protéger,
une interaction ou une relation sociale avec quelqu'un, quelqu'un qu'on estime, quelqu'un avec qui on est proche.
On a parfois besoin de faire un petit mensonge blanc. Donc, c'est des petits mensonges qui n'ont aucune valeur en réalité, qui n'ont que pour objectif de garder cette relation la plus paisible possible.
Le mensonge le plus simple, c'est quand quelqu'un vous demande si il ou elle a pris du poids, vous lui dites : Bien sûr que non.
Même si c'est vrai, parce que ça peut heurter la personne de dire : Oui, tu as pris du poids. Souvent, ces petits mensonges n'ont aucune conséquence, si ce n'est de garder cette relation relativement intacte.
Certains diront qu'il vaut mieux prôner l'honnêteté radicale. Alors, c'est pas ma posture, parce que je pense qu'avec l'honnêteté radicale, on risque d'être plus dans une posture de vérité qui fait mal,
plutôt que dans une posture de communication et d'échange bienveillant.
On reviendra sur un profil de personne qui prône une honnêteté radicale.
Donc là, on a bien posé le contexte sur ce qui t'a attiré vers le mensonge, les petites subtilités, les petits couacs dans la communication.
Si je devais te demander les idées reçues au sujet du mensonge, qu'est-ce que les gens croient au sujet du mensonge qui est en fait totalement faux ?
Alors, il y a un paquet d'idées reçues sur le mensonge. Vraiment. C'est quelque chose qui a éveillé vraiment beaucoup de fantasmes.
En utilisant le mot fantasme, notamment, ça me ramène à Freud, puisque je sais que tu as accueilli Jacques Van Rillaer dans le podcast.
Freud est notamment à l'origine de cette croyance que le lapsus révélerait une pensée qu'on essaye de cacher et qui surgit quand même.
Une forme de mensonge quelque part.
Est-ce qu'il y a encore beaucoup de gens qui croient ça ? Parce que moi, ça me paraît complètement pété comme théorie. Est-ce qu'on croise vraiment des gens dans la rue qui disent : « Ah, t'as fait un lapsus ».
Le nombre de fois qu'un lapsus se produit et qu'on dit : « Ah ah, lapsus révélateur ».
C'est pour la vanne, ça.
Souvent. Mais beaucoup de gens semblent encore croire que certains lapsus-
Avec un fond de suspicion.
Pourraient suggérer quelque chose. C'est pas la croyance la plus répandue.
En soi, ça peut arriver un lapsus révélateur.
Bien sûr.
Voilà.
Bien sûr, tout à fait.
Mais j'essaye d'en pas faire. Ça, j'en fais pas tard.
Ça peut arriver, mais c'est extrêmement rare et il y a... Un lapsus peut être un mensonge, mais tout lapsus n'est pas mensonge.
Ok. Une autre idée reçue au sujet du mensonge.
La croyance la plus répandue, c'est celle du regard qui part, qui se détourne du regard de l'autre pour aller se figer dans un coin quelque part, ce qu'on appelle les cadrans du regard.
Oui, ce que j'ai beaucoup entendu, c'est si on réfléchit pour retrouver une information dans sa mémoire, on regarde en haut à droite.
Par contre, si on a honte et qu'en fait, on est en train de dire un mensonge et qu'on a envie de pas se faire attraper, là, on va regarder en bas à gauche, dans un coin du visage, dans le coin du regard et que, voilà.
Est-ce que c'est vrai ?
Non.
Ok.
Voilà.
Voilà qui est clair.
Mais l'explication est assez intéressante, c'est que c'est une croyance qui vient de la programmation neurolinguistique.
D'accord.
Qui était originellement une pratique thérapeutique basée sur des pratiques communicationnelles. L'idée était de mieux comprendre ce que le client, dans une relation en psychothérapie, peut penser, peut exprimer à l'aide de ses yeux.
Ok, pourquoi pas ? Donc, il y a un système
visuel, olfactif, kinétique, auditif qui se représenterait dans le regard et, en fonction de si on regarde vers le haut, vers le bas ou au centre et, à gauche vers le passé, à droite vers le futur.
C'est-- alors, les explications là-dessus, déjà, divergent beaucoup en fonction de qui écrit sur le sujet.
C'est ça, oui. Ça me rappelle un peu la psychanalyse dans le sens du truc très, on a envie de donner du sens à chaque chose et tout ça est très, tout ça est écrit dans notre nature et tout ça et...
C'est un peu ça, oui. C'est l'idée aussi que le corps est cette carte qu'on peut arriver à lire pour percer les mystères inconscients de la pensée de l'autre.
Non, non, on va le dire simplement, pas à ce point-là. On peut apprendre des choses à partir de la communication et du comportement non verbal de l'autre, mais pas ça.
C'est ça.
Donc voilà, déjà, le système des yeux qui divergent à gauche, à droite, en haut, en bas diffère en fonction des auteurs.
Donc ça, c'est un premier problème. Mais au-delà de ça, les scientifiques se sont quand même posé la question : pourquoi pas ?
Mh.
Admettons.
Est-ce que les menteurs dévient du regard ou est-ce que les personnes honnêtes gardent le contact oculaire ?
Alors, ils dévient du regard.
Oui.
Les menteurs dévient du regard, mais comme une personne authentique.
Oui, oui.
Et ils dévient à gauche, à droite, au centre, vers le haut, vers le bas. Ça part dans tous les sens et il n'y a pas un cadran spécifique qui nous permettrait de dire : Ah, il regarde en haut à gauche.
Ouh là là là là là là.
Oui, c'est ça.
On a affaire à un menteur.
Oui, oui, puisque toi et moi, là, maintenant, on est en train de dévier du regard. C'est quelque chose de tout à fait naturel.
En fait, ça nous permet-- généralement, on remarque que les gens détournent le regard pour se concentrer.
Mh.
Pour réfléchir à quelque chose. Et autant quand je dis la vérité que quand je dis le mensonge, aux dernières nouvelles, j'ai besoin de réfléchir.
Oui. Est-ce que ça t'est déjà arrivé quand tu étais étudiant et que tu devais faire une présentation orale ou quoi,
on te reprochait de regarder dans le vide pendant ta présentation, pendant que tu réfléchissais ou quelque chose, au lieu de fixer le jury dans les yeux ?
Moi, ça m'est arrivé un paquet de fois.
Alors, ça m'est arrivé dans des situations assez diverses.
D'accord.
J'ai fait notamment des arts de la scène à un moment et du coup, le premier réflexe, c'est de ne pas regarder.
Ne pas regarder.
Le public.
Oui, oui.
C'est-- et en fait, en parlant avec le public après, on me dit : « Mais en fait, on sent que vous récitez votre texte, que vous êtes perdu dans votre tête et que vous cherchez la prochaine ligne ».
Je dis : « Mais non, c'est juste une convention, je ne vous regarde pas pendant que je joue
». Et du coup, j'ai commencé aussi par moi-même à essayer de regarder les gens pendant que je donne cours, par exemple, ou pendant que je présente quelque chose.
Visiblement, ça aide à les garder intéressés.
Ça a dû être un effort actif pour toi quoi. C'est pas quelque chose qui t'est venu naturellement.
Épuisant.
C'est épuisant.
D'accord. Je pose la question parce que donc j'essaie de bien contextualiser les choses, mais c'est pas le cas de tout le monde, ça, c'est une particularité chez toi.
Tout à fait. J'ai vraiment essayé, surtout dans les interactions en un versus un, de garder le plus possible le contact visuel.
Oui.
C'est pas facile parce que si on essaye de faire que ça, c'est un effort constant, on ne sait plus ce qu'on dit, on perd le fil et voilà, c'est très compliqué.
Du coup, on détourne le regard parce que ça nous permet de nous concentrer, ça nous permet d'être dans notre bulle.
Est-ce que tu dirais que tout le monde est comme ça
? Ou est-ce que c'est un sous-groupe de personnes ? Parce que,
parce que encore une fois, moi, on m'a reproché pendant une présentation orale de : « Hé, mais vous regardez le sol pendant que vous parlez, pendant que vous expliquez votre truc ».
J'ai l'impression que la norme, c'est plutôt de regarder les gens dans les yeux.
C'est une bonne question.
Oui.
J'avoue que je n'y ai pas la réponse.
Ok.
Mais je me doute qu'il doit y avoir en effet des variations au sein des individus et de certains groupes, en effet.
Certains groupes ?
On y reviendra. Mais...
Quelle autre idée reçue ? Parce que là, on a beaucoup parlé du-
Du regard.
Du regard, oui. On peut digresser, mais quelles autres idées reçues au sujet de--
On peut parler du fait qu'on s'attende à ce que le menteur soit nerveux.
Ok, ça peut être le cas, pas forcément.
Ça peut être le cas, bien sûr, mais pas forcément. Et donc tous les éléments qui vont derrière la nervosité, c'est-à-dire le fait de se toucher,
le visage, de se gratter, voilà, le fait de gigoter quand on est assis, de pas pouvoir tenir en place quand on est debout, le fait de transpirer.
L'idée reçue comme quoi on se touche le visage, on se gratte, tout ça, c'est absolument faux. Il y a rien qui est vérifié à ce niveau-là ?
Il y a rien et on aurait même tendance à dire que c'est le contraire.
Ok.
C'est que, on rentrera peut-être dans les détails là-dedans, mais quand on ment, on fait un effort qui est plus intense.
Et quand on fait un effort qui est plus intense, on est tellement concentré sur ce qu'on dit que gestuellement, on bouge moins.
Le corps, en fait, est moins sollicité tellement on fait l'effort de garder une narration structurée, claire, la plus crédible possible.
Et du coup, on a tendance à bouger moins les mains notamment. Donc on se gratte moins, on bouge moins de manière générale quand on ment.
Ok, ok, intéressant. On reviendra sur la question de la détection de-
Mh.
..du mensonge. D'autres idées reçues à corriger ? Ou on a fait le tour des plus grandes ?
Non, simplement dire qu'en Belgique, on a toujours une manière d'évaluer la crédibilité dans les interrogatoires de police qui est légale, qui est le polygraphe.
Mh.
Et que le polygraphe se base notamment sur cette idée de nervosité.
Ah oui, oui.
Et que c'est un petit problème. Il y a une vidéo avec des enfants qui est géniale où ils mettent une passoire sur la tête d'un enfant.
Mh.
Cette passoire, elle est connectée à une pseudo machine et ils leur posent des questions et parfois la machine s'allume.
Et l'enfant se dit : Ouh là là, qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Il répète la vérité qu'il était en train de dire, elle se rallume et il se corrige vers quelque chose qui est faux au final.
Mh.
Juste pour que la machine ne s'allume plus.
Ah oui. Ça, c'est une bonne expérience un peu de la psychologie sociale ou ?
C'est de la psychologie sociale. C'est l'idée que à force de dire : Vous mentez, vous mentez, on risque d'amener des fausses confessions-
Ouais.
Qui parfois sont extrêmement graves. De plus en plus de documentaires aujourd'hui sortent sur ces questions-là et tout l'Innocence Project, qui est ce projet mené aux États-Unis et dans le monde,
cherche à trouver ces éléments de fausses confessions,
qui ont été menées notamment par l'usage d'outils fallacieux.
C'est ça, oui. Oui, oui. Et t'as eu l'occasion de travailler sur ces questions-là ?
Alors, j'ai eu l'occasion de travailler à plusieurs reprises avec la Police Nationale française, la gendarmerie, le ministère des Armées.
Voilà, 'fin, des personnes qui sont en fait au contact de plusieurs outils divers et variés. Notamment en France, il y a eu à une époque l'usage d'un
logiciel de détection de micro-tremblements dans la voix,
qui est un ordinateur Dell à quatre cent euros et un micro qui doit coûter dix euros.
Voilà. Sauf que ça a été vendu très très cher et que c'est resté dans une armoire pendant très longtemps.
Heureusement.
Heureusement quelque part, parce que ce genre d'outil a été utilisé aux États-Unis, dans le cadre notamment d'entretiens d'embauche, dans le cadre de passages de frontières, à la douane et dans le cadre d'entretiens de police,
et que ces outils, en fait, ont mené à des fausses confessions parce que l'outil détectait un mensonge, on ne sait pas trop comment, alors que la personne en face de nous était en train de clairement dire la vérité.
Mh.
Et à force d'être interrogée pendant des heures et des heures et de pouvoir essayer de se dédouaner, mais qu'au final, on n'en peut plus, on va finir par produire une fausse confession.
Ouais, ouais.
On a-- 'fin, je ne sais pas si tu as été un jour en commissariat pour être entendu. Moi, oui.
OK.
Et je n'ai pas eu à passer le polygraphe, heureusement, parce que le poly-- non, non, le polygraphe n'est généralement utilisé que dans des cas de crimes graves.
Moi, c'était en tant que témoin. Donc voilà.
Mais j'aurais bien aimé savoir un petit peu ce qu'il en est. Mais en fait,
être en commissariat et être entendu par un policier, c'est déjà un événement stressant qui va causer de la nervosité, une augmentation du rythme cardiaque, de la transpiration et une respiration beaucoup plus rapide.
Du coup, une personne tout à fait sincère peut renvoyer des signaux de nervosité. Et a contrario, une personne qui est en train de mentir peut tout à fait être à l'aise avec son mensonge, ne ressentir aucune nervosité-
Mh.
..et passer le test du polygraphe les doigts dans le nez.
Oui, je suis certain que Donald Trump pourrait passer un test du polygraphe sans aucun problème.
Parfaitement. Parfaitement.
Voilà. Pour résumer, en tout cas.
Le seul problème, c'est qu'il y a quelques années, la Belgique a donné un cadre légal à l'utilisation du polygraphe.
J'allais te poser la question. Quelle valeur est-ce que ça a dans un procès ?
Alors, ça n'a pas valeur de preuve, heureusement.
OK.
Mais le polygraphe peut être requis ou demandé volontairement.
Par la personne interrogée ?
Par la personne interrogée. Ce qui est un problème si elle ne sait pas que ça peut causer des faux positifs assez rapidement.
Oui, mais tant que le rés-- 'fin, si le résultat n'a aucune valeur, on peut le demander, on peut l'utiliser, on s'en fout.
Alors, ça aura un impact.
Mh.
Mais ça ne pourra pas être produit pendant le procès en disant : Regardez, cette personne ment, elle est coupable, etc.
Ça aura un impact dans l'enquête.
Voilà, exactement. Et ce que les gens ne savent pas en général, c'est qu'il y a en fait une bonne manière d'utiliser le polygraphe.
Mh.
La manière dont on l'utilise en Belgique, c'est une manière très classique, c'est de la détection de nervosité en supposant que ça va-
Indiquer le mensonge.
Indiquer le mensonge. C'est l'équivalent de lancer une pièce en l'air et dire : Pile il ment, face il dit la vérité.
Et la bonne manière, ce serait ?
La bonne manière, elle est un petit peu plus complexe, mais elle est beaucoup plus fiable.
Mh.
Imaginons, Guillaume, que tu m'assassines en ce moment même...
Je l'imaginais déjà.
Voilà. Avec un couteau de cuisine. Tu m'assassines ici et tu es entendu par la police. Tu es branché au polygraphe.
D'accord ? Et l'officier de police qui est devant toi va te dire : Je vais vous présenter cinq armes.
D'accord.
Et il te présente un pistolet, un chandelier, un couteau.
Une corde.
Mh. Mh.
En fait, spontanément, toi qui as cette information de l'arme du crime, tu sais quel couteau a été utilisé pour m'assassiner. Ton corps va réagir en voyant l'arme du crime.
Mmh.
Et ça, le polygraphe est capable de le détecter. Là où une personne qui n'aura jamais vu l'arme du crime fera une flat line complète sur les cinq.
Donc, ouais, donc là, même pas nécessaire de poser une question, d'interroger, d'avoir une réponse ou quoi, c'est juste-
Exactement. Ça veut dire que c'est une méthode qui est un petit peu plus safe au niveau des fausses confessions.
Mmh.
C'est une méthode qui détecte pas vraiment le mensonge, mais ça détecte en fait des souvenirs. Tu es le seul à avoir le souvenir de l'arme du crime-
Si tu m'as tué.
Oui.
Et c'est fiable. Alors ça vaut toujours pas comme preuve, bien sûr.
Oui, j'allais te demander, ouais, parce qu'il y aurait un moyen-- quelqu'un pourrait connaître ce procédé-
Exactement.
Et puis le détecter et être nerveux, se dire : « Ils sont sur le point de me pincer ».
Tout à fait.
Puis devenir nerveux. Et puis ouais.
Tout à fait. Ça n'a toujours pas valeur de preuve, mais au lieu de passer d'un pile ou face, c'est-à-dire un taux de chance qui est à cinquante pour cent, on passe à nonante, nonante-cinq pour cent de détection correcte.
Très bon épisode de Law & Order.
Exactement.
Voilà.
Exactement. Et ils ont toujours pas répondu à mon email.
OK. Donc ça, c'est pour le polygraphe. Est-ce qu'on a fait le tour au niveau des idées reçues, des choses à corriger dans l'esprit ?
On a fait un bon tour, en tout cas.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Simplement pour clôturer, simplement garder à l'esprit en fait que si on souhaite améliorer le taux de détection au niveau du mensonge, le non-verbal et la voix, il faut oublier.
D'accord.
Il n'y a rien.
Et se concentrer sur quoi, alors ?
Les mots.
Sur les mots qui sont utilisés, les structures de phrases.
Ah oui.
Et les quantités de détails, etc. En fait, des choses qui tombent sous le sens.
Vas-y, explique-nous, explique-nous.
Quand on ment, il y a plusieurs principes qui se mettent à l'œuvre. Premièrement, on fait un effort beaucoup plus intense.
Mmh.
Mentir, c'est une étape en plus de dire la vérité, c'est-à-dire qu'on va dire : « Je ne dis pas la vérité ».
C'est un processus créatif.
Exactement. Je dois peut-être partir de la vérité et modifier quelques petites choses ou ne pas partir du tout de la vérité et créer autre chose.
Mais il y a en tout cas cette étape supplémentaire qui est l'inhibition de la vérité pour créer quelque chose de nouveau.
Bon, ça, c'est la première étape. La deuxième, c'est qu'on a tendance, et c'est important pour ce dont on va discuter probablement après, il y a le besoin de suivre un fil rouge simple.
Pas trop de complexité ?
Pas trop de complexité.
Un besoin pour être crédible ou un besoin pour euh...
Les deux. Pour être crédible, parce que les histoires simples sont celles qui sont le plus simples à comprendre et donc à croire, mais aussi pour le menteur, parce que plus l'histoire est complexe, plus il y a des chances que ça crée
un endroit où le menteur va trébucher et se confondre.
Donc, on va avoir tendance à simplifier le mensonge. Ça nous mène à deux choses. Premièrement, on se rend compte de manière quasi unanime que les menteurs utilisent moins de mots.
OK.
On utilise moins de mots pour mentir que pour dire la vérité.
Ce que j'ai déjà pu entendre, c'est que justement, le menteur rajoutait beaucoup de détails superflus pour essayer de noyer le mensonge.
C'est le deuxième point auquel j'arrivais. Excellent.
Magnifique.
Le deuxième point, c'est qu'il y a en effet ces espèces de menteurs prolixes, hein, qui aiment déblatérer une quantité impressionnante de détails, mais ce sont des détails, en fait, comme tu l'as dit, c'est des détails superflus.
Mmh.
Et généralement, ce sont des détails qu'on va décrire comme invérifiables.
C'est vrai, oui. Oui, le genre, il faisait très beau ce jour-là, machin.
Exactement. La technique du noyer le poisson, c'est rajouter plein de détails qui donnent une illusion de crédibilité.
Ça fait une belle chantilly.
Ouais.
Mais dans la chantilly, il y a très peu de choses qu'on peut vraiment utiliser.
OK. Donc à la fois une ligne rouge très simple et en même temps des détails qui viennent ponctuer ce fil rouge très simple pour un peu masquer le fait que c'est très simple.
C'est ça. C'est comme quand on rate une pâtisserie, on essaie d'en mettre des couches par au-dessus pour faire en sorte que ça soit joli.
Si tu le dis.
Voilà. Si, si. Il n'y a pas du tout d'expérience là-derrière. Mais l'idée principale du mensonge, c'est : je vais avoir moins d'informations à donner.
Je vais avoir un fil rouge beaucoup plus simple. Et si je veux rajouter toute cette surcouche de détails, en général, ces détails sont pas vérifiables.
Donc là, on parle vraiment évidemment du mensonge parlé.
Mmh.
Et le mensonge par omission, est-ce que ça fait partie des choses que tu as...
Alors, le mensonge par omission, je l'ai toujours trouvé fascinant.
OK.
Parce que c'est justement là où il diverge complètement de ce que moi, je fais. Il m'empêche d'avoir du matériel sur lequel travailler.
Le mensonge par omission, c'est vraiment éviter de dire quelque chose. Là où ça m'intéresserait, c'est de faire peut-être une étude en imagerie pour voir si cérébralement, il y a un effet d'inhibition qui s'activerait
Intéressant.
quelque part et qui pourrait potentiellement nous dire que tiens, là, on a des zones qui se retrouvent dans les capacités euh...
On va revenir sur la question de l'imagerie quand on parlera notamment de la question de la détection computationnelle.
On parlait tout à l'heure de personnes qui mentent beaucoup, une petite minorité. Qui sont-ils ? Pourquoi ? Est-ce que c'est une pathologie ?
Quels sont leurs réseaux ?
Quels sont leurs réseaux ? Alors, il y a en effet un petit pourcentage de la population qui ment énormément comparé au reste.
Oui.
On est sur des taux qui vont vingt fois, cent fois plus.
OK.
Donc ce sont des gens qui, dans leur communication quotidienne, sont en train de mentir très régulièrement.
Alors, ces gens sont communément connus sous l'appellation de mythos, des mythomanes, ou alors, comme on aime bien les appeler dans la littérature scientifique, parce qu'on aime bien donner une étiquette bizarre à tout,
des gens qui sont atteints de pseudologie fantastique.
OK.
C'est beau, mais ça veut dire exactement la même chose que la mythomanie. C'est en gros des gens qui ont une maladie, dans ce cas-là.
C'est une pathologie clinique qui fait qu'en gros, leur mensonge devient leur propre réalité.
D'accord, ouais.
Ils s'enlisent tellement dans leur mensonge que la vague les submerge et ils sont obligés de perpétuer le mensonge jusqu'à ce que, j'allais dire jusqu'à ce que mort s'ensuive, mais pour certains, oui.
C'est jusqu'au bout.
Y a quelques visages, quelques noms qui me viennent en tête quand tu dis ça. Je sais pas, spontanément, enfin, on en connaît tous, des gens comme Alex Jones aux États-Unis ou Donald Trump ou des politiques belges.
C'est vrai, c'est vrai, mais en même temps, ces gens, je pense, j'espère-
C'est difficile de faire un diagnostic plus-
Ont encore conscience qu'ils mentent.
Conscience.
Ils sont encore au fait-
OK
...du mensonge qu'ils sont en train de produire.
Donc rappelle-moi le nom du diagnostic ?
Pseudologie fantastique.
Pseudologie fantastique. Ces gens n'ont même plus conscience de-
Ces gens n'ont même plus conscience qu'ils mentent. En fait, ça devient leur nouvelle réalité. Un exemple qui est assez connu,
je vais peut-être massacrer son nom parce que j'ai un doute, mais aux États-Unis, il y a un juge qui, dans mon souvenir, s'appelle le juge Van Couwenberg-
OK
...avec un nom bien de chez nous, qui en fait n'a jamais passé le barreau, qui n'a pas de diplôme d'avocat-
...et qui a présidé des tribunaux pendant toute sa carrière jusqu'à ce qu'on se rende compte qu'en fait, pas du tout. Donc c'est
c'est quelqu'un qui représente communément cette idée de mythomanie, c'est qu'il a menti sur ses capacités, sur ses diplômes et qu'on l'a cru,
mais que comme on l'a cru, il a été obligé de
continuer à mentir, à mentir et à mentir.
C'est intéressant parce que là, on parle de pathologie, donc dans le cas de gens qui ont vraiment un bug dans le cerveau, qui font qu'ils ont tout à fait perdu pied, perdu le contact avec la réalité.
Et donc finalement, les gens que je citais juste avant, les Alex Jones, à ce moment-là, c'est politique. C'est des gens qui font un choix de mentir.
Alors qu'on disait mentir typiquement une à deux fois par jour, ces gens-là mentent beaucoup plus, mais ce n'est pas pathologique, c'est politique, c'est ça ?
Je pense, à nouveau, premièrement, je n'ai pas de master en psychologie, donc je ne peux pas mener de diagnostics cliniques.
Je n'ai pas accès à ces personnes non plus, donc c'est très difficile à déterminer. Je pense en fait que ces personnes sont très conscientes de ce qu'elles font,
que pour eux, en fait, c'est pas tant une question de ne plus être conscient du fait de mentir, c'est que le mensonge pour eux n'a
plus de différence de valeur avec la vérité.
C'est ça.
Les deux, en fait, les-
Pour beaucoup de gens, c'est douloureux de mentir.
C'est ça.
Pour eux, c'est comme une aspiration.
C'est profitable en fait de mentir. Donald Trump a menti parce que ça lui a permis de déstabiliser énormément de gens, parce que ça lui a permis de gagner, de garder le contrôle sur certaines affaires.
Ouais. Et simplement parce qu'il aime bien être au centre de l'attention, recevoir des compliments, etc. Donc, il dit : Oui, mon université, c'est la meilleure, tout le monde le dit.
Tout à fait. C'est très vrai. Et puis, son usage de Twitter aussi a été extrêmement problématique puisque-
Oui, le post-truth era.
Exactement. C'est--
ça existait déjà un petit peu avant lui, mais en effet, on a commencé à parler de cette ère de la post-vérité où en fait, l'idée est que dans cette nouvelle ère, vérité et mensonge se confondent et ont la même valeur.
Ouais. Donc, on partait du constat que les gens mentent typiquement et c'est normal de mentir une à deux fois par jour. Puis, on a, ok, des profils pathologiques qui ont complètement perdu pied.
Et puis, il y a cette autre catégorie un peu entre les deux qui arrive à ne plus sentir un impact négatif du mensonge.
Comment est-ce qu'on arrive à se détacher de cette pénalité-là ?
Alors, il y a des traits de personnalité qui impliquent le mensonge.
D'accord, comme ?
Alors, c'est un grand mot parce qu'on l'utilise généralement à tort et à travers, mais la psychopathie, par exemple-
D'accord
...est notamment caractérisée par l'usage du mensonge sans que ça ne nous fasse ni chaud ni froid.
Mh.
Est-ce que ça veut dire que tous les hommes politiques et les femmes politiques qui mentent sont des psychopathes ? Non, pas forcément.
Mais il y a en fait certains éléments de personnalité, des éléments contextuels. Les campagnes aux élections, il y a des mensonges dedans.
Est-ce qu'on peut se forcer à mentir et trouver ça douloureux, culpabiliser et puis le faire, continuer à le faire, le faire de plus en plus et se retrouver désensibilisé à cette violence qu'on se fait à soi-même ?
C'est ce qu'on découvre en fait chez les enfants.
OK.
Les enfants, quand ils commencent à mentir, généralement, surtout quand ils se font avoir, ressentent de la honte, de la culpabilité, parfois du plaisir.
On va pas se mentir. Ils peuvent ressentir la joie d'essayer de duper quelqu'un. Et de la nervosité, bien sûr.
Mais plus on ment, plus ces éléments émotionnels ont tendance à disparaître, plus le problème moral a tendance à disparaître aussi.
Et en fait, on s'habitue au caractère commun du mensonge. Ça ne nous fait plus ni chaud ni froid en fait de mentir.
Ouais, OK. Et donc c'est largement politique en fait ce truc. C'est, on évolue dans un contexte qui
nous récompense pour le mensonge et donc on le fait de plus en plus, de plus en plus et puis on devient accro peut-être pour certains.
Pour certains, c'est possible. Oui, tout à fait. Ce qui est intéressant à constater, c'est ce qui se passe après leur vie politique.
Oui, c'est bon parce que tu tournes vraiment autour des politiciens, toi.
Ah mais dans ce cas-ci, en tout cas, oui, c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe une fois que le mandat prend fin et qu'ils doivent retourner à la vie civile.
Est-ce qu'ils sont encore dans cet usage complètement démesuré du mensonge ou pas ?
Oui. Ça, c'est où ? Est-ce que...
On n'en sait rien. Et c'est un des axes que j'aimerais bien suivre, mais pour ça, il faut...
Il faut trouver des politiciens qui acceptent le...
Voilà. Donc si vous entendez ce message
Si vous êtes un politicien véreux. OK. Donc là, on a parlé des profils donc qui mentent énormément. Parlons des profils qui n'aiment pas du tout mentir.
Parlons des autistes.
Oui. Alors, j'ai interrogé justement une amie autiste, en lui disant que j'allais t'interviewer toi et elle me demandait : pourquoi les gens font ça ?
Pourquoi les gens mentent ? Alors on a répondu à cette question-là. Donc du coup, je vais te poser une autre question, c'est pourquoi est-ce que les autistes sont aussi dégoûtés par le mensonge,
aussi peu à l'aise avec l'idée de mentir et ainsi de suite ?
Alors, premièrement, je fais un disclosure immédiatement, l'autisme n'est pas du tout ma spécialité.
D'accord.
Mais je me suis renseigné sur le sujet pour essayer de-- parce que je me doutais que cette question allait arriver.
Du coup, voilà, je me suis renseigné un petit peu sur la question du mensonge et de l'autisme. Alors la question du dégoût en tant que telle, je ne sais pas.
J'ai regardé, j'ai essayé de trouver pourquoi des gens autistes ont euh-
OK. Je vais pouvoir te le dire alors. Tu t'es renseigné un peu et du coup, qu'est-ce que-
Alors, je me suis renseigné sur le-- donc il y a un grand stéréotype qui court depuis les années nonante où on dit que les personnes qui ont un trouble du spectre autistique sont incapables de mentir.
C'est pas tout à fait vrai.
Voilà, exactement. Donc c'est ça que j'ai voulu aller vérifier. Premièrement, il y a tout le côté prosocial qui a tendance à réduire la volonté de mentir chez les personnes autistes.
Qu'est-ce que-- est-ce que tu peux paraphraser, employer un mot que je vais comprendre ?
En gros, c'est toute la complexité de l'interaction.
Ouais, ouais, c'est ça, OK.
Alors il y a plusieurs raisons pour ça, notamment l'idée selon laquelle lorsqu'on est autiste, on serait moins capable d'attribuer des intentions, des émotions, des pensées à autrui
et que mentir dans ce cas-là devient compliqué, parce que si on ne sait pas ce que l'autre a en tête, c'est difficile de savoir s'il va croire en notre réalité ou pas.
Il y a aussi le fait que les personnes qui seraient sur le spectre auraient aussi, comment dire, moins de relations sociales avec d'autres gens et que ce serait du coup plus compliqué. Alors, je-
Mh.
Je ne fais que dire ce que j'ai lu.
Oui, oui. C'est un peu...
C'est peut-être un peu réducteur.
Oui, c'est-- oui, c'est complètement stéréotypé, ça.
Et puis enfin, il y a un côté fonction exécutive, donc tout ce qui a trait à la mémoire, à la concentration, etc.
Le mensonge, ça requiert un effort de concentration assez intense, de mémoire assez complexe. Et d'après cette étude que j'ai lue, ce serait compliqué aussi.
Mais j'insiste, je ne suis pas expert du tout sur la question.
Ouais, c'est-- oui, non, c'est pas... T'as pas de certitude, mais...
Je n'ai aucune certitude là-dessus.
De manière générale, quand on parle d'autisme, on parle beaucoup au conditionnel, etc. Ça reste encore un peu mystérieux.
Donc t'as très bien répondu en ce qui concerne le pourquoi ça peut être compliqué de mentir, donc notamment en ce qui concerne ce que moi, je vais appeler l'empathie cognitive, le fait de pouvoir se projeter
dans les chaussures de la personne à qui on parle.
Et finalement, l'autre question que tu as évoquée, c'est-à-dire pourquoi est-ce que ça nous dégoûte ? Pourquoi est-ce que ça nous semble injuste ?
Et pourquoi ça nous énerve ? Et encore une fois, je dis nous, mais ça dépend très fort d'une personne à l'autre.
Donc les auditeurs, les auditrices de Septante Minutes ont pu remarquer qu'il y avait plusieurs personnes que j'ai interviewées qui partageaient un certain dégoût au sujet du mensonge pour plusieurs raisons.
C'est pas toujours la même. Si je refais un peu le tour des personnes que j'ai pu interviewer, il y en a qui me disaient que : « Mais comment est-ce que c'est possible ?
Ce serait tellement beaucoup plus simple si tout le monde disait la vérité tout le temps. Comment est-ce que... C'est vraiment, c'est injuste.
C'est ignoble de mentir. » D'autres personnes qui me disaient : « J'ai pas de problème avec la justice de la chose, l'éthique du mensonge, mais j'ai pas l'agilité mentale pour arriver à faire un mensonge crédible ou quoi.
Enfin, je trouve ça compliqué. C'est pas facile. Ça me vient pas naturellement. » Donc pour ce qui est de-- et moi, par exemple, j'ai un regard un peu plus ambigu, c'est-à-dire que
si c'est pour abuser de quelqu'un, c'est jamais non.
Mais si c'est pour me protéger, pour qu'on m'emmerde pas, je peux mentir pour qu'on me lâche les baskets quoi.
Et donc je pense qu'on l'évoquait un peu plus tôt, ce serait quand même compliqué si on devait tout le temps dire la vérité.
Et bien, la personne que j'évoquais tout à l'heure, en fait sa technique, c'est plutôt la fuite. C'est-
D'accord.
C'est, si on m'envoie un message sur Messenger et que j'ai pas envie de répondre parce que c'est gênant, je fuis, je ne réponds pas, je ghost.
Et voilà. Ça a pu briser dans son cas, ça a pu briser des amitiés comme ça.
Tout à fait.
La technique de la fuite. Et donc pour répondre à ta question de pourquoi ça nous énerve autant. En fait, ma théorie, et je parle au conditionnel, c'est que donc comme on...
Par exemple, tu me mens et moi, je te crois très naturellement parce que j'ai des difficultés pour me projeter, me mettre dans tes baskets et me dire : « Hum.
Sur base du contexte, sur base de ses intentions, sur base de ses objectifs, tout ça, il pourrait ou il est probablement en train de me mentir.
Je pense qu'il est en train de me mentir. »
Mh.
Bon, ça, encore une fois, ça dépend d'une personne autiste à l'autre, mais peut-être que moi ou une autre personne autiste aurait tendance à dire : « Ben non, je la crois sur parole.
J'ai pas de raison de me méfier. » Encore une fois, le biais de l'honnêteté très très fort, peut-être chez certaines personnes autistes, beaucoup de personnes autistes.
Et puis un peu plus tard, tu m'avoues : « Ben non, tu m'as menti. »
Mh.
Et là, je tombe des nues, je fais : « Mais comment c'est possible ? Comment ? » Je ne l'imaginais même pas. Je tombe de très très haut.
C'est violent, c'est pas agréable, etc.
D'accord.
Et ça se passe une fois, deux fois, trois fois, quatre fois, cinq fois. Et au bout d'un moment, c'est vraiment une rage.
Mais comment c'est possible que les gens soient comme ça, me mentent ? Et c'est un décalage avec ce qui est finalement une norme, être neurotypique.
Et pour toute une série de raisons, ce décalage et cette incompréhension devient déjà un goût d'injustice.
Mh.
Et de par son côté répété, devient vraiment énervant quoi.
Mh. C'est une rupture de la confiance en fait qui se produit.
Oui.
Et plus elle est répétée, en fait, plus elle a tendance à-
Et elle sera répétée.
D'accord.
Parce que c'est inévitable hein. Les gens mentent.
Malheureusement, oui.
As-tu dit malheureusement ?
Non, mais c'est, 'fin, heureusement et malheureusement, y a vraiment ce côté très ambivalent en fait dans le mensonge.
Voilà.
Du bien et du mal, mais je-- d'accord, je comprends.
Ok, ben donc voilà. Donc ça, c'était pour la parenthèse autisme.
Mais je serais... Alors par contre, je suis très intéressé de travailler sur ces sujets-là.
Ok. Pourquoi ?
Parce que moi-même, j'ai pu avoir des stéréotypes vis-à-vis de l'autisme, bien sûr.
Mh.
Et plus je lis dessus, en fait, plus je me rends compte que j'y connais rien.
Ok.
Et au niveau du mensonge, y a des choses qui sont faites, mais il y a des choses qui sont faites très expérimentalement.
Mh.
Et je trouve qu'on donne pas la parole aux personnes autistes. Ce que tu viens de me raconter, par exemple.
Ouais.
Je n'avais jamais lu ça auparavant. J'avais jamais entendu ça. Et je trouve qu'en fait, il y a peut-être une autre vision à apporter à la question.
On parlait tout à l'heure de la détection des mensonges, donc via la nervosité, à quel point ça ne marche pas. Et tu m'expliquais que ton doctorat, c'était justement basé sur la détection de mensonges, de manière computationnelle.
Mh.
Par ordinateur.
Du coup, est-ce que ça marche ? Quelles sont les conclusions auxquelles tu es arrivé ? Comment ça va ? Explique-moi l'idée de cette technologie-là, comment est-ce qu'elle fonctionne ?
Alors, il y a deux idées.
Je suis informaticien, donc c'est parfait.
D'accord, mais je vais quand même essayer de faire en sorte que nos auditeurs comprennent. Y a deux idées. Premièrement, vous pouvez faire, à l'aide d'un logiciel tout simple, une analyse de chaque mot qui est présent dans le texte.
Ok.
On peut lui donner une fréquence, à quel point il est présent dans le texte. On peut lui donner une forme de couleur émotionnelle, à quel point c'est un mot positif ou négatif.
Mh.
On peut aussi lui donner des fonctions grammaticales. C'est un verbe, c'est un nom, c'est un adjectif.
Donc, ce qu'on appelle du language processing. On regarde la fréquence des mots, leur sens.
Exactement.
Le contexte, tout ça.
Tout à fait.
Et donc on ne prend pas en compte des facteurs liés à la nervosité, liés au regard, liés à tous ces trucs-là.
Exactement.
Parce que comme tu disais, on part du principe que ça n'a aucune importance.
Alors dans ma thèse, j'ai tenté de répliquer l'hypothèse de nervosité dans le langage. C'est-à-dire que quand on est nerveux, on va en fait utiliser des mots davantage négatifs.
Ok, on va peut-être un peu plus employer des gros mots, on va peut-être un peu plus-
On va employer des gros mots, on va mentir. Le mensonge le plus simple, c'est de mettre une négation. D'accord ? Négation, pas négation, c'est le mensonge le plus simple possible.
Je suis un homme, je ne suis pas un homme.
C'est ça.
C'est l'un et l'autre.
Mh.
C'est un mensonge, c'est le mensonge le plus simple.
Ouais.
J'ai regardé si on avait plus de négations quand on mentait. J'ai regardé si on avait plus d'émotions négatives qui pouvaient inspirer de l'anxiété, qui pouvaient inspirer peut-être de la tristesse ou de la colère.
Toutes des émotions qui pourraient être attachées à de la nervosité et ce qui s'ensuit derrière. Il n'y a rien.
Ouais.
Zéro. Nada.
Ouais, mais pourquoi est-ce que tu choisis de creuser la piste de la nervosité si tu n'y crois pas à la base ?
Parce que la plupart des études qui ont été faites sur la nervosité se font au niveau non verbal.
Oui, oui.
Et en fait, pendant très longtemps, on a négligé le verbal.
Mh.
Et quand on est passé vers le verbal, en fait, on a oublié les émotions quelque part.
Ouais.
On s'est intéressé sur la fréquence des mots, à quel point est-ce qu'ils utilisent tel ou tel mot, etc. Mais cette hypothèse de nervosité, en fait, elle avait jamais été testée dans le langage même, dans les mots qu'on utilise.
Donc je me suis dit : Bon ben allons voir, enfin on sait jamais.
L'opportunité de-
Parce que le menteur peut être nerveux. Rien, zéro.
D'accord.
Ça commence mal. La deuxième voie qu'on peut suivre est un petit peu plus compliquée à expliquer, mais c'est l'idée qu'on ne va pas prendre le mot en tant que mot séparé, mais on va le prendre dans un contexte.
Donc on va voir que quand je regarde le mot bien, je vois qu'il est souvent entouré de mots comme manger, et le mal, il y a en fait des mots qui tournent autour régulièrement.
Ok.
D'accord ? On suppose du coup que lorsque les personnes mentent, elles vont faire cet effort un peu créatif, elles vont essayer de sortir de la vérité et de suivre une voie qui est autre.
Et donc ils vont modifier leur langage pour ça. Pour ça, on s'attend à ce qu'ils utilisent des phrases simples et donc avec des mots qui sont toujours à peu près dans le même contexte.
D'accord ? Comparé à la vérité où les mots peuvent varier un petit peu plus les uns avec les autres.
Ok.
On utilise des modèles très complexes d'analyse, en natural language processing, en traitement automatique du langage, avec ce côté boîte noire de l'algorithmie, et on atteint des taux de détection qui sont pas négligeables.
On arrive à nonante, nonante-cinq pour cent.
En travaillant principalement avec la question du contexte.
Voilà. Mais là où on a un problème du coup, c'est qu'on sait pas pourquoi.
Parce que, pour expliquer aux gens, quand on lance un algo de deep learning, on lui donne beaucoup de data, on le laisse s'entraîner, s'entraîner, s'entraîner.
Au bout d'un moment, il devient, certains diraient intelligent, il devient compétent en tout cas pour-
Pour une tâche spécifique.
Voilà. Et donc il a sa technique, mais on ne la connaît pas.
On peut pas ouvrir la boîte et dire : Ah, mais c'est comme ça que ça marche.
Donc impossible de trouver le code source quelque part.
Exactement. Impossible de revenir sur les mécanismes qui font qu'on est capable, au final, d'arriver à un truc très très bien.
La question, là, du coup, devient un problème éthique. Admettons qu'un jour cette intelligence artificielle soit capable de détecter le mensonge dans nonante-huit, nonante-neuf, nonante-neuf virgule cinq pour cent des cas.
Actuellement, c'est quoi le score ?
En moyenne, on est aux alentours de nonante, nonante-deux. C'est assez impressionnant.
C'est super puissant.
C'est très très puissant, mais moi-
Et il est dispo quelque part ce truc ou quoi ?
Oui oui oui oui, il y a des algorithmes dispo en open source.
Ce sont des boîtes noires, donc ça, ça peut pas être...
Tout à fait, mais on a l'algorithme d'entraînement. C'est-à-dire qu'on sait quelles instructions sont données. Mais on ne sait pas à quel point l'algorithme, le réseau, en gros, évolue pour apprendre.
Ok, ok.
C'est imprédictible. Et du coup, oui, mais du coup, on arrive à nonante, nonante-deux, nonante-cinq pour cent. Admettons qu'un jour, on arrive à nonante-huit, nonante-neuf, nonante-neuf et demi, probablement jamais cent pour cent, mais...
Et ça, c'est toujours en anglais ou ça marche indépendamment de la langue ?
Ça marche indépendamment de la langue.
Ok. Ça marche en japonais ? Ça marche-
Ça marche dans des langues, alors pas le japonais. Qu'est-ce que j'ai vu ? J'ai vu
j'ai vu des langues dont le nom m'échappe, mais ce sont des langues d'Asie du Sud-Est, donc des langues qui sont pas des langues alphabétiques comme les nôtres, qui n'ont pas l'alphabet latin, par exemple.
Il a un nom, cet algorithme, pour que je puisse l'utiliser sur mes invités ?
Alors, je l'enverrai, je le communiquerai. Je sais qu'on est parti de Word2vec, qui était la première version, et maintenant, on est sur BERT, B-E-R-T.
BERT, ok.
Qui est aussi en open source. Je crois qu'on est même à BERT deux point zéro maintenant.
Ok, ok.
Et oui, c'est vraiment très très impressionnant à voir.
Je comprends pas pourquoi on n'en parle pas plus.
Je suis d'accord. Et c'est utilisé sur des corpus assez larges de mensonges, du coup, des quantités de données assez impressionnantes.
Du coup, ils utilisent des fausses opinions concernant des restaurants, concernant des reviews Amazon, concernant des—
Mais oui, justement, j'allais te demander si, par exemple, moi, je dis : j'aime pas les tomates.
Par exemple.
Enfin, si l'ordinateur n'a pas plus de contexte que ça, pour être vrai, ça pourrait être faux.
Exactement. C'est pour ça qu'on n'arrivera jamais à cent pour cent.
Ok.
C'est qu'il y a toujours des messages qui sont trop courts. Le mensonge le plus commun de tous les jours, c'est : ça va.
Oui oui, bien sûr.
C'est une convention, mais c'est un mensonge.
Oui. Donc difficilement détectable sur base de uniquement le—
Exactement.
Natural language processing.
Mais si on applique ces méthodes dans le cadre judiciaire, on a des entretiens qui font des heures, on a suffisamment de données.
Admettons demain que cette intelligence artificielle soit capable de distinguer un vrai témoignage d'un faux témoignage.
Oui, la question éthique se pose.
À nonante-neuf pour cent.
Oui oui oui. La question éthique se pose de savoir est-ce qu'on fait confiance à l'ordinateur, est-ce qu'on lui donne une valeur, une valeur juridique.
Et mon opinion, ce serait de dire qu'on ne peut pas l'utiliser.
Mmh.
Parce qu'on ne sait pas comment on est arrivé là.
Oui, c'est ça, oui.
D'accord, le résultat est là, très bien, bravo. Mais pourquoi ? Comment ? Quelles sont les raisons derrière ?
Et du coup, est-ce que tu dirais à la police d'arrêter d'employer le—comment ça s'appelle encore le truc ?
Ah, le polygraphe.
Le polygraphe, oui, c'est ça. Est-ce que tu dirais à la police belge d'arrêter d'employer le polygraphe et d'employer BERT à la place ?
Ou un équivalent ?
Ce serait pas pire. Je vais le dire comme ça. Ce serait pas pire. Ce serait peut-être mieux en fonction de la quantité de données qu'ils ont.
Oui, c'est ça.
Je pense qu'ils ont—
S'ils l'emploient sur ça, va, ça va être—
Ce qu'on appelle des verbatim d'entretien, donc des retranscriptions pures et dures d'entretien. S'ils en ont, il en faut pas tant que ça.
Cinq cents, ça suffit pour entraîner correctement un algorithme. L'idéal, après, c'est de voir bien sûr ce que l'algorithme produit.
Il va dire c'est honnête ou c'est mensonger. Et en fonction de l'issue de l'affaire, dire en effet, c'était authentique ou mensonger, ou alors l'algorithme s'est trompé, corriger l'algorithme et relancer après la machine.
Donc c'est de l'apprentissage avec un humain dans la boucle, mais je pense que si la police veut développer cette technologie-là, ce sera clairement meilleur que s'il se base sur le polygraphe.
Et donc tu souhaiterais que ce soit le cas ou bien tu gardes une position un peu neutre ?
Si c'est pour faire avancer une affaire et qu'on arrive au préalable avec ce qu'on a déjà à des taux de détection qui sont plus que bons—
Mmm-hmm.
Et par là, je compte quatre-vingt-cinq pour cent et plus, alors pourquoi pas. Mais c'est toujours à garder à l'esprit comme une nouvelle pièce—
Ouais.
Qu'on ajoute—
Mais quatre-vingt-cinq pour cent, c'est pas cent pour cent quoi donc—
Non, non, non, on a encore quinze pour cent d'erreurs, c'est immense.
Ouais.
Mais c'est... voilà, moi, je pense que c'est pas inutile. C'est pas pire que le polygraphe, ça, c'est certain.
C'est vrai que c'est quand même très facile de tomber dans le piège, de dire : ouais, quatre-vingt-cinq pour cent, c'est énorme, je peux lui faire confiance.
Alors, y a—
Alors qu'en fait pas vraiment.
Il y a beaucoup de—on parlait des biais tout à l'heure.
Ouais, ouais.
Il y a un biais d'automatisation.
C'est ça.
Où on a tendance à dire : oh, c'est une machine, elle est capable de faire beaucoup mieux que moi, elle est capable de faire des choses incroyables, je vais la croire par défaut.
Ou alors le contraire, de dire : c'est une machine, elle n'aura jamais la capacité humaine à prendre des décisions comme il faut.
Moi, je connais beaucoup mieux la chose et à négliger quelque chose qui est produit par une machine.
Donc ça, c'est pour le Natural Language Processing.
Mmm-hmm.
Si on parle de, et tu l'as évoqué tout à l'heure vis-à-vis du mensonge par omission, si on parle de scanner un cerveau, de regarder ce qui se passe à l'intérieur.
Mmm.
Est-ce que t'as pu travailler, t'as pu lire des choses là-dessus ?
Alors, donc étant linguiste et m'étant orienté vers la psychologie, la neuro n'est pas mon grand domaine d'expertise.
Je m'en doute.
J'ai ouvert deux, trois publications sur le sujet. Il n'y a pas une zone particulière du mensonge de nouveau dans le cerveau. Ça n'existe pas.
D'accord.
Ça, on le sait. Il y a quelques études intéressantes qui semblent montrer un mouvement lié à cette complexité du mensonge.
Mmm-hmm.
Le mensonge étant plus complexe, on a des zones différentes qui s'allument par rapport à la vérité, mais elles se chevauchent relativement beaucoup.
Et puis, pas de la neuro, mais quand même intéressant, il y a des études complètement folles, j'ai envie de dire, qui mesurent la température du visage.
Comme quoi, quand on mentirait, en fait—
Il y a le nez qui pousse.
Eh bé, il serait plus froid. C'est—oui, alors, on dit dans le milieu que le nez de Pinocchio n'existe pas, mais le titre de leur publication, c'est « Le nez de Pinocchio existe, mais il est froid ».
Donc, c'est quoi ? C'est crédible ? C'est...
Ça a été reproduit plusieurs fois. C'est très bizarre. L'explication est purement physiologique, sans avoir vraiment de raison pourquoi.
Mmm.
Ce serait lié à l'idée qu'il y a quand même un peu de nervosité dans le mensonge et que le sang aurait tendance à s'échapper vers les extrémités.
Tu dirais à la police d'employer ça ?
Non, pas du tout. Déjà parce qu'une caméra thermique, ça coûte très très cher, surtout de bonne qualité. Autant investir dans un petit algorithme et...
OK. On a évoqué donc les questions de détection du mensonge par la police. Quand on vient déposer une plainte, par exemple, pour agression sexuelle, pour viol auprès de la police, on n'est pas toujours cru, malheureusement.
Rappelle que l'écrasante majorité, je ne sais plus exactement combien, nonante-sept pour cent, nonante-trois pour cent ?
Ça dépend des statistiques, ça dépend des pays, ça dépend des documents disponibles. En moyenne, on tourne aux alentours de nonante-cinq pour cent de—
Nonante-cinq pour cent, dit-on, des allégations, des plaintes pour viol sont—
Vraies.
Véridiques, ouais. Et donc toi, tu choisis de travailler sur la petite minorité de menteurs, menteuses. Pourquoi ?
Alors déjà, ça rejoint le début du podcast.
Ouais.
Tout ce qui sort de ce qu'on attend et ce qu'on peut supposer comme normal, entre guillemets, m'intéresse beaucoup.
Mais au-delà de ça, je m'y intéresse pas tant parce que je pense que ces cinq pour cent ont une importance vitale, mais parce que je suis très au fait que la police en elle-même les trouve plus présents que cinq pour cent.
Ah oui, oui.
En gros, il y a un décalage entre la réalité du terrain—
Bien sûr.
Et ce qu'on suppose dans les rangs des forces de l'ordre.
Est-ce que travailler sur—est-ce que ça sert à quelque chose, ce que tu fais ? Est-ce que travailler sur les fausses accusations de viol peut, je te challenge, peut avoir un impact positif sur les biais de ces policiers ?
Alors, il y a beaucoup de questions dans ta question, en l'occurrence.
Bien sûr.
Je vais commencer par—
Septante Minutes Avec, bonjour.
Une chose. Faux ne veut pas dire mensonger.
Intéressant.
Les fausses allégations de viol—
Mmm.
Ne sont pas toutes mensongères.
Ça peut être une mauvaise interprétation.
Exactement.
Un regret, un quiproquo.
Tout à fait. Ça peut être énormément de choses. Ça peut être notamment lié au fait que la loi est parfois compliquée à comprendre.
Mmm-hmm.
Je suis retourné lire l'article trois cent septante-cinq du code pénal ce matin pour voir les changements qui—
Pour préparer ce podcast.
Absolument. Et voir les changements qui ont été apportés récemment, en l'occurrence. Alors, j'ai la définition ici, on peut la lire.
« Tout acte de pénétration sexuelle, de quelque nature qu'il soit et par quelque moyen que ce soit, commis sur une personne qui n'y consent pas, constitue le crime de viol. »
Donc il faut pénétration.
Il faut pénétration sexuelle.
C'est pas fini. « Il n'y a pas consentement quand l'acte a été imposé par violence, contrainte, menace, surprise ou ruse, ou a été rendu possible en raison d'une infirmité ou d'une déficience physique ou mentale de la victime. »
Donc une contrainte, un chantage, ça, ça rentre—
Ça rentre dedans.
Ça rentre dedans, OK.
Le chantage tombe sous l'idée de la ruse.
Mmm-hmm.
C'est pas fini parce qu'en dessous de ça, il y a des nouvelles choses. On ajoute là-dessus le fait que la personne est considérée—enfin, on considère qu'il y a viol lorsque la personne est inconsciente ou endormie,
ou qu'elle est menacée, donc sous l'effet de la peur, ou qu'elle est intoxiquée par de l'alcool, de la drogue ou des psychotropes divers et variés.
OK. Donc c'est—je sais pas, ça me semble être plutôt complet parce que—
C'est assez complet, tout à fait, mais ça rend du coup l'idée du viol très précise comparé à l'idée d'une agression sexuelle.
D'accord.
Une agression sexuelle, il ne faut pas forcément qu'il y ait pénétration.
Du coup, parfois, dans ces fausses allégations de viol, on retrouve en fait des erreurs qui sont en fait des allégations d'agression sexuelle qui ont été déposées comme allégation de viol.
OK.
Donc y a pas de mensonge derrière. Il y a simplement une mécompréhension de ce que c'est un viol et de ce que légalement le viol représente.
D'accord.
Ça, c'est la première partie. La deuxième partie, en effet, il y a des mensonges. Ça arrive, bien sûr. Mais on essaie de comprendre pourquoi la personne a menti.
Qu'est-ce qui a poussé cette personne à venir porter plainte pour viol alors qu'il n'y a pas eu viol ? Il y a plein de motifs pour lesquels on peut faire ça.
Nous, on s'est intéressé à la question du regret. Le regret, c'est on a un acte sexuel consensuel qu'on regrette par la suite.
Ouais.
Le regret, ça mène à ce qu'on appelle une dissonance cognitive, c'est-à-dire un écart entre ce qu'on voudrait qu'il se soit passé et ce qui s'est réellement passé.
Et on peut alors un peu réécrire la réalité.
On essaye de rationaliser, on essaye de réduire cette dissonance de plein de manières différentes, simplement en acceptant, ça peut être : « Je regrette ce qui s'est passé, ainsi soit-il.
» Ou alors en essayant de réécrire, en effet, ce qu'il s'est passé.
On peut inclure beaucoup d'autres éléments là-dedans, la présence d'un environnement social qui, lui, par contre, peut voir autre chose que ce qui s'est réellement passé, qui va faire pression, etc.
Pour savoir, oui, c'est une forme de pression, des conseils de—
Tout à fait.
Donc—
Et donc ça, c'est ce qu'on a essayé de structurer un petit peu pour présenter ça à la police.
OK.
Pour leur expliquer, en fait, déjà, toute fausse allégation n'est pas mensongère. Et il se peut aussi que ce soit simplement une rationalisation de quelque chose qui est regretté et qu'on a—
qui a mené à de la dissonance cognitive.
Donc c'est plus complexe en fait de dire les fausses allégations, c'est des mensonges. On essaye vraiment de développer plus en détail ces 5 % pour dire en fait, c'est pas 5 % de mensonges, c'est moins que ça encore.
Mmm-hmm.
Et du coup, en pratique, à quoi est-ce que ça devrait mener ?
Dis-moi.
On essaye de faire comprendre aux gens que quelle que soit, aux gens, pardon, aux officiers de police, que quelle que soit la personne qui vienne porter plainte pour agression sexuelle ou viol, il y a une probabilité telle que ce soit vrai.
Et que quoi qu'il en soit, la manière dont l'entretien doit se dérouler doit se dérouler en prenant en compte cette déclaration comme vraie.
Une présomption de légitimité-
Présomption de légitimité.
Présomption d'innocence.
Exactement.
On n'est pas en train de déposer une fausse plainte.
Exactement. Ce qu'on remarque, par contre-
Fausse plainte, peut-être, mais-
Une fausse plainte, c'est possible, mais pas forcément mensongère.
C'est ça.
Ce qui vient compliquer un petit peu la chose, un petit peu hein, c'est le fait que, au sein de la police, on a remarqué qu'il y a beaucoup de croyances par rapport au viol qui sont à côté de la plaque.
Il y a beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle des mythes du viol qui sont en fait des croyances stéréotypiques de ce qu'est un viol.
L'idée que ça se passe dans une ruelle et qu'on se fait agresser par un inconnu, alors que la plupart du temps, c'est par quelqu'un de son entourage.
Quelqu'un qu'on connaît, dans un endroit qu'on connaît. Il y a aussi-
Majoritairement des victimes femmes.
Voilà.
La plupart du temps.
Tout à fait. Alors, petite parenthèse là-dessus, je lisais aussi qu'il y a en fait des victimes hommes, bien entendu.
Bien sûr.
Mmm, et que ces victimes hommes rapportent encore moins les viols que les femmes.
Oui, ça, on peut l'imaginer.
Voilà. J'ai trouvé ça intéressant, je l'ignorais. En fait, c'est d'une part parce qu'ils ne comprennent pas visiblement qu'il y a eu un viol, ça arrive, ou alors simplement le fait que,
il y a une pression de la société sur l'homme violé qui est,
problématique également et que voilà, il ne porte pas plainte non plus.
Le patriarcat-
Ça nuit à tout le monde.
Fait effet sur eux aussi, ouais.
Voilà, ça nuit à tout le monde. Fin de la parenthèse. Ces stéréotypes, en fait, ils vont même au-delà du viol même.
Ils vont aller jusqu'à critiquer le comportement de la victime. « Ah, mais madame, si vous étiez dehors à cette heure-là, qu'est-ce que vous faisiez ?
Vous étiez habillée comme ça. Ah, vous êtes rentrée avec cette personne-là, ça veut dire que vous le vouliez quand même un petit peu.
» C'est très présent. C'est vraiment très présent dans les-- alors, chez les hommes, majoritairement, et dans les rangs des forces de l'ordre aussi.
OK, ouais.
Il y a des études sur la détection des fausses allégations de viol mensongères. Ça existe.
Mmm-hmm.
Il y a notamment une étude récente là, qui a comparé des étudiants, des officiers de police lambda et la brigade des mœurs.
Ok.
Les trois sont aussi peu capables de détecter le mensonge dans les fausses allégations de viol, l'un que l'autre. Ça, on le savait déjà, j'ai envie de dire.
Ça fait à peu près une heure qu'on en parle.
Ouais.
Voilà. Là où ça pose plus problème, c'est qu'on a aussi mesuré la confiance de chacun.
Mmh.
Et qu'on a remarqué que les membres des forces de l'ordre, officiers de police lambda et brigade des mœurs, ont une confiance beaucoup plus élevée-
Dans leur intuition
...dans leur intuition-
Ouais
...que les étudiants. Et ça pose un problème parce qu'ils supposent du coup que ces fausses allégations, en fait, suivent un pattern d'improbabilité.
Mmh. Oui, puis surtout, enfin, les policiers sont l'exécutif.
Mmh.
Ils sont pas juges.
Non, non.
Donc employer leur intuition pour écarter un dépôt de plainte, c'est très problématique.
Tout à fait. C'est non, c'est un problème majeur. Et c'est encore plus un problème que, si on revient au tout début de notre entretien-
Mmh
...on sait que le menteur a tendance à faire un récit qui est davantage conforme à un stéréotype, à une ligne rouge qu'on connaît.
Et il y a des études qui montrent que, en effet, les fausses allégations mensongères sont davantage proches des stéréotypes du viol.
Mmh. Auxquels ces policiers croient.
Auxquels ces policiers croient comme étant vrais.
Ouais, alors qu'ils sont-
Alors qu'elles sont plutôt à tendance fausse.
Ouais.
Là où les récits sincères d'agression sexuelle ou de viol ont, eux, par contre, des spécificités telles qu'on a tendance à les considérer comme pas crédibles.
Notamment, il est ressorti que les policiers ont tendance à dire : « Oui, un viol, en gros, c'est un endroit, une personne, un acte sexuel, une position. » Et voilà.
C'est une série de critères, une série de-
Voilà
...patterns et...
Là où on s'est rendu compte que les vraies allégations de viol, ce sont plusieurs actes sexuels,
une personne qu'on connaît, pas un inconnu, et qu'en fait, il y a tout autour de l'acte, d'autres éléments qui ne sont jamais discutés dans les stéréotypes.
Mmh.
Il y a une phase de contact, il y a le ou les rapports. Et puis, en fait, il y a une phase postérieure à tout ça qui ne ressort jamais dans les fausses allégations mensongères.
Et donc, le--
c'est la question que je te posais à la base, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a donc ces croyances dans les stéréotypes, cette volonté d'écarter
les dépôts de plainte, les histoires, les témoignages qui ne se rapprochent pas de ces stéréotypes et qui sont...
voilà, on peut être violé par son mari, par exemple.
Mmh.
C'est quelque chose qui est certainement moins crédible, malheureusement, aux yeux des policiers. Donc ça, c'est le fruit, donc, d'un certain sexisme, d'une certaine misogynie.
En quoi est-ce que les travaux de recherche sur les accusations mensongères peuvent aider à résoudre ce problème qui est principalement un problème de sexisme et de misogynie ?
Alors, étant donné qu'ils en sont le résultat-
Mmh
...c'est compliqué de les utiliser pour régler le problème en tant que tel.
Ouais.
Par contre, ça permet de pointer du doigt là où le problème se trouve. En effet, comme tu le dis, c'est un problème qui est beaucoup plus structurel-
Mmh
...que simplement le fait qu'on croit en des stéréotypes.
Et pour ça, on doit revenir à une source qui est plus large, qui est la présence du sexisme, la présence du machisme, du masculinisme, la présence de-- alors, en plus de ça, récemment, tout ce qui est anti-wokisme-
Ok
...qui s'ajoute, on a une étude qui est en cours sur ce sujet-là.
En France ou en Belgique ?
On l'a fait tourner en France et en Belgique.
Ok, ok. Parce qu'en France, c'est vrai qu'on...
Oui.
Je sais pas, je pense que c'est moins le cas en Belgique, mais on--
il y a ces chiffres qui ressortent régulièrement pour montrer les proximités entre les syndicats policiers, les policiers de manière générale, avec des idées plutôt fascistes.
Tout à fait.
En Belgique, c'est le cas aussi ? Tu sais ça ?
Alors, il y a très peu d'études sur le milieu policier en Belgique.
Bah ouais.
Malheureusement.
Ça aurait été bien de savoir ça.
Ça aurait été bien de savoir ça, mais on sait que de manière générale, même s'il n'y a pas d'études locales-
Mmh
...toutes les unités de police qui ont été sondées dans plusieurs pays occidentaux-
Sont plutôt de droite
...ont une tendance conservatrice.
Ouais.
Voilà.
C'est ça. Oui, donc, on peut se douter qu'en Belgique francophone, vu qu'il n'y a pas de parti fasciste actuellement-
Mmh
...quoi qu'on en dise, le-- bon, c'est plutôt bon signe vis-à-vis des policiers, mais effectivement, je pense qu'on peut se douter que c'est plutôt des gens qui aiment l'ordre, qui-
Voilà. Tout à fait.
Quelque chose comme ça.
Donc, il y a très clairement en fait tout un travail à faire au niveau du recrutement.
Mmh.
Il y a un travail à faire au niveau de la sensibilisation.
Et est-ce que tu-- ce qu'on disait vis-à-vis du fait qu'ils ont fortement confiance en leur intuition.
Exactement.
Ça, c'est même pas une question de sexisme et de fascisme ou de machisme. C'est une question de compétence, de sérieux dans son travail.
C'est... On essaye en plus de trouver des explications, mais le moyen le plus direct, c'est la formation.
Oui. Oui, mais donc, pour revenir à la question que je posais, c'est : OK, on ne résout pas le problème grâce à tes travaux, mais on pointe techniquement du doigt là où ça coince.
Exactement.
Là où il y a un problème et on
On essaie de remonter à la source du problème. Tout à fait. Tout à fait. L'idée, c'est de dire : « Bon, là, ça cloche, là, ça cloche, là, ça cloche.
Est-ce qu'on a une source commune qui cause ces problèmes ? »
Souvent, oui.
Probablement.
Oui.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour enrayer le problème ? Et là, je veux bien, de toute bonne volonté que je suis, en tant que petit chercheur, ça va être compliqué.
C'est ça. C'est pas-
Par contre, ce qui serait intéressant, c'est de faire des tests.
Des tests de quel type ?
On peut voir si dans les procédures de recrutement, en ajoutant telle ou telle mesure d'évaluation de la personnalité, telle ou telle mesure de l'engagement, ou de croyance en certains systèmes conservateurs,
on peut améliorer les conditions,
d'entretien pour les personnes qui viennent porter plainte pour agression sexuelle ou viol, par exemple.
OK.
On peut sélectionner peut-être plus précisément les personnes qui vont prendre ces plaintes.
Mh.
Et choisir des personnes qui sont peut-être plus conciliantes avec ces mythes du viol. Puis aussi, on est en train de réfléchir avec des collègues à la question
: quand on a un officier de police qui vient prendre le dépôt de plainte, est-ce que le fait de faire le dépôt de plainte face à une intelligence artificielle, par exemple, pourrait simplifier la tâche ?
C'est une question.
C'est une question. Et on a le soupçon, avec des collègues écossais, que l'intelligence artificielle, qui n'aurait en fait que des questions à poser,
n'aurait pas autant de biais que l'officier de police et pourrait donc potentiellement favoriser un entretien peut-être plus agréable et des éléments concernant l'événement plus,
plus, de faciliter en fait l'arrivée de la déclaration de certains détails qui pourraient faire avancer l'enquête.
Et ne serait-ce que favoriser un meilleur entretien et peut-être même une meilleure image de la police, par extension.
Ça me paraît tout à fait sensé. Frédéric, on a bien dépassé les septante minutes. Est-ce qu'y a quelque chose que tu souhaites rajouter vis-à-vis du mensonge, vis-à-vis des allégations, des accusations mensongères,
et de tout ce qu'on a pu dire ?
Des questions que tu as pour moi ? Est-ce que tu veux qu'on parle d'autisme pendant encore une demi-heure ?
Non, je pense qu'en fait, on a tellement
d'images en tête sur ce qu'est le mensonge, d'un point de vue social, d'un point de vue moral, et souvent d'un point de vue pratique aussi, qu'on est régulièrement à côté de la plaque.
OK.
Et que nous devrions peut-être prendre un pas de recul. Et
je vais prêcher pour ma paroisse, consulter des gens qui travaillent sur le sujet pour mettre en place des systèmes larges pour à la fois mieux détecter le mensonge, ça, c'est une première question, mais aussi
empêcher la production du mensonge le plus possible.
Quand on ment, c'est qu'on a une raison quelque part et il y a des outils qu'on pourrait mettre en place pour favoriser l'authenticité, l'honnêteté plutôt que le mensonge.
C'est intéressant parce qu'on a commencé en disant que le mensonge était légitime, normal, habituel. Et là, tu me dis : « Il faudrait qu'il y en ait quand même le moins possible. »
En tout cas, dans certains cas.
Comme ?
Comme les affaires juridiques, par exemple, où
Oui.
On a vu la toile se déchirer récemment sur le procès Heard-Depp, sans aucune validité, sans aucune mesure de quoi que ce soit, sans aucune réflexion au-delà de « Elle ment, elle ment, elle ment ».
Mh.
Et
ben en fait, dans le cadre judiciaire, on se rend compte que simplement élaborer un rapport
de sincérité, d'honnêteté et de sympathie, d'empathie avec la personne qui vient faire le dépôt de plainte, c'est la première étape pour que, potentiellement, l'authenticité soit mieux révélée
OK.
dans l'entretien.
Magnifique. Merci beaucoup, Frédéric.
Merci à toi.
Et à très bientôt. Au revoir. Et voilà, j'espère que vous en avez appris autant que moi sur les menteurs et les mensonges.
J'espère que cet épisode vous a plu. Si c'est le cas, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée et n'oubliez pas de parler de Septante Minutes Avec autour de vous.
Petit erratum, le nom du juge non diplômé américain, c'était Couwenberg, pas loin. En revanche, le modèle de deep learning s'appelle bien BERT.
Dans les semaines qui viennent, on devrait avoir droit, j'espère ne pas vous mentir,
à une série d'épisodes plus incroyables les uns que les autres, avec notamment cet épisode sur les troubles du comportement alimentaire, que je vous promets depuis longue date.
Un épisode avec une politicienne bruxelloise pas comme les autres, je ne vous en dis pas plus. Et normalement aussi un épisode sur les stratégies médiatiques des djihadistes.
Voilà, je pense que vous ne vous attendiez pas à ça. Ce sera au mois d'octobre et, si vous avez des suggestions d'invités, surtout, n'oubliez pas de me les communiquer.
Et quant à moi, je vous dis à très bientôt. Salut, salut.